what's trending what's trending well
we've actually been asking people with
their hidden talent is flamenco I have
separate control over my eyeballs high
bar what about you dad my skilled driver
I can't prove it right now but you can
take my word for it I'm actually a very
good like dancer at weddings you put on
a little Rihanna and if I've had a glass
of champagne I can do some sweet moves I
do fancy myself a really good ball
player but maybe people will say
something else who plays ball with me
yeah I can pick up things with my toes
yes really well
oh this is horribly creepy you really
want to see this then it works in a race
and it made me win because other guys
that was starting limelight I can crack
my ankles toes knees hit neck back
wrists elbows all of it I'm jealous I
can't crack all my going rock is hip and
that's what I knew it was true love I
can cry like a baby
it's king everyone is if they have a
hidden talent you know do something fun
with your tongue or maybe you can cross
your eyes over there because I don't
think it's a hidden talent for a reason
it's so [ __ ] up you guys just shut up
you did you start smoking before you
came here today